[Musik]
gleich zum Einstieg stellen wir euch die
Millionenfrage nach was es ist eher eine
milliardenfrage warum gibt es kein
europäisches Google und um ein paar
provokante Fragen draufzusetzen warum
hat Europa weder Apple noch Amazon
hervorgebracht aus welchem Grund ähnelt
Europas Wirtschaft er einen
versteinerten Dinosaurier Friedhof als
einem dynamischen sprudelnden
die Europäer Tesa und all das nur weil
Europa die alte Welt und Amerika die
neue Welt ist kann irgendwie nicht sein
wenn die chinesische Zivilisation ist
noch älter als die europäische und
ebenfalls drauf und dran gut old Europe
technologisch abzuhängen
um euch eine Vorstellung zu geben von
den fünf größten Unternehmen der Welt
stammen vier aus den USA und sie wurden
nach 1975 gegründet Europas größte
Unternehmen wurden hingegen schon viel
früher gegründet einige Wien ist leer
oder Roche stammen aus dem 19
Jahrhundert
[Musik]
keine Frage diese Unternehmen verdienen
unseren Beifall allein dafür dass sie es
geschafft haben bis heute auf den Markt
zu bleiben aber es ist doch bezeichnet
das unter Europas Top 5 kein einziges
Junges Unternehmen ist denn hinter dem
vergleichsweise jungen Tabellenführer
LVMH verbergen sich die französischen
Luxusmarken Louis Vuitton und eine sie
und die gab es zum Teil sogar schon im
18 Jahrhundert ganz anders sieht es
dagegen in den USA aus wo drei der fünf
größten Unternehmen jünger sind als
viele von euch Politik Publikum und das
beweist schon mal eines die USA sind
Europa in Sachen Innovation weit voraus
aber das heißt natürlich nicht dass es
Europa keine Unternehmen die innovativ
sind zwei Beispiele sind SAP mit seiner
Unternehmenssoftware oder Skype diese
Firmen wurden in Deutschland und Estland
gegründet aber im Vergleich zu den
Vereinigten Staaten gibt es bei uns nur
wenige solcher shootings-stars dieses
Defizit war bislang nur eine weitere
Debatte unter vielen in Europa doch
jetzt wird sie vielleicht so wichtigsten
Debatte der nächsten Jahre und das liegt
an der Energiekrise
[Musik]
die aktuelle Krise Treffen mit ihrem
exorbitanten Strom und Gasrechnungen
fast alle Bürger genauso oder vielleicht
noch schlimmer sind davon aber
Unternehmen betroffen und da wird die
Sache heikel denn wenn diese Unternehmen
global aufgestellt und dementsprechend
flexibel sind dann könnten sie eine
siegenden Europäischen Union schlecht
weg den Rücken kehren und sei es nur
weil Gas und Strom anderswo günstiger zu
haben sind gelingt es dem energiekrieger
Blondine Putin der schon seit
Jahrzehnten sinkenden
Konkurrenzfähigkeit der europäischen
Industrie den endgültigen Todesstoß zu
versetzen die traurige Wahrheit lautet
nun mal die EU ist nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähiger als die Vereinigten
Staaten oder China in ein paar Jahren
könnte die Europäische Union deshalb wie
ein Detroit von kontinentalen Ausmaßen
wirken wenn Ihr treuer verloren dieses
Kanals seid dann wisst ihr was es
bedeutet Detroit zu sein
Arbeitslosigkeit Slums und Kriminalität
und miserable Zukunftsperspektive wie
einst in der Sterbenden us-automatropole
Detroit ist die Automobilindustrie auch
in ganz Europa ein großer Bedeutung
nicht nur für Frankreich und Deutschland
sondern vor allem auch für Spanien und
Italien kurzum der Vergleich mit Detroit
ist kein schlechter Scherz aber wie kann
dieses Schicksal abgewendet werden wie
könnte sich Europa stattdessen einem
anderen amerikanischen
Entwicklungsmodell annähernd dem Silicon
Valley und könnte da der Krieg in der
Ukraine diesbezüglich die Europäische
Union reanimieren könnte es ausgerechnet
werden sein der Europa mit einem lange
überfälligen Arschtritt wieder zu neuer
Vitalität verhält heute werden wir all
diese Fragen beantworten zuvor möchte
ich euch aber einen heißen Tipp für den
Fall geben dass ihr euer Englisch auf
ein perfektes Level bringen möchtet zum
Beispiel um gleich ins richtige Silikon
Valley auszuwandern denn was ist die
Königsdisziplin beim Erlernen einer
Fremdsprache ganz genau eine perfekte
Aussprache und jetzt haltet euch fest es
gibt einen sehr innovativen und für
jeden zugänglichen Weg diese so leicht
zu lernen wie nie zuvor mit der genialen
Englisch lernen
unseres Sponsors Elsa das Besondere an
ihr sie analysiert die Fehler in deiner
Aussprache durch modernste
ki-algorithmen so vergleicht sieht eine
Aussprache mit der eines
Muttersprachlers bewertet deinen
Redefluss und deine Betonung zeigt dir
alle deine Fehler und erstellt auf
Grundlage dessen dann ein auf dich
individuell abgestimmtes stufenweises
Trainingsprogramm für jeden einzelnen
laut aber schauen wir uns doch mal an
wie das ganze funktioniert vielleicht
wird mein Englisch durch elsaja auch so
toll dass ich irgendwann auf dem
englischen visualpolitik Kanal
einspringen könnte also ich habe jetzt
schon den Einstufungstest hinter mir und
was empfiehlt mir Elsa also irgendwie LR
und the ja damit das weiß ich das ist so
meine Schwachstelle gucken wir mal was
der mir jetzt hier anbietet wie ich das
ganze verbessern kann also da kommen
erst mal Videos da wird das Ganze
erklärt aber die will ich jetzt auch gar
nicht sondern ich will gleich in die
Übung einsteigen so das ist das hier ist
die Übung erstmal easy ganz easy
ich spreche das jetzt mal bewusst falsch
aus wie ja darf man nicht so aussprechen
ich habe wie gesagt das ist so ein
typische deutsche Aussprache
okay was kommt als nächstes what ich
spreche mal wieder falsch aus what
bitte geht doch wenn ja ist halt falsch
ne und ich kann jetzt auf den Fehler
draufgehen und hier steht eine Erklärung
was genau ich machen soll um den laut
richtig auszusprechen ich kann mir das
sogar vorlesen lassen
ja es ist halt kein böse sondern ein Ohr
also probieren wir es mal richtig
auszusprechen wenn
sehr gut aber schauen wir uns doch noch
mal die thematischen Übungen an die sind
nämlich auch ganz witzig okay study by
topic was klingt interessant
relationship habe bitteschön Online
Dating ja da braucht man gute Aussprache
womit man sonst Punkten was ist hier
planning in first date meeting at the
café running late oh ja zu spät kommen
zum Date nur als kleiner Schütte Test
Traffic traffic
ja wo will uns das Programm hier
eigentlich thematische
im Stau ich war halt im Stau stuck and
traffic
nicht so doll ist die habe ich irgendwie
schlecht ausgesprochen
okay und das dieses ah eh okay also
probieren wir es noch mal
stuck and traffic ja das habe ich immer
noch zu deutsch ausgesprochen ne stuck
and traffic oh sehr gut mit diesem auch
deine tatsächlichen Schwachstellen
fokussierten Trainingsprogramm kannst du
nicht nur deine sprecherweise und
Intonation gezielt korrigieren sein
nebenbei auf viele weitere Vokabeln
Rasen und Sätze für die tägliche
Kommunikation lernen damit kannst du
deine Englischkenntnisse so schnell
effizient und vor allem unterhaltsam
perfektionieren wie nie zuvor Elsa
bietet über 1600 Lektionen aus 40
Themenbereichen von Business Englisch
über Bewerbungsgespräche bis zum Flirt
und reisevokabular und als Sahne
Körbchen auch noch spannende und
unterhaltsame Community-Funktionen
möchtest du zum Beispiel außer von der
KI auch von realen Menschen aus der
ganzen Welt lernen oder zusammen mit
einem Kumpels und Kollegen bei einer
Sprachwettbewerb antreten das alles und
noch viel mehr bietet Elsa in einem
bisher wirklich konkurrenzlosen Angebot
und natürlich gibt es sowieso alle
politikzuschauer wieder ein ganz
besonderes einführungsspecial in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video findest
du zwei Links mit dem ersten kannst du
Elsa kostenlos herunterladen und die Pro
Version für 7 Tage testen mit dem
zweiten gelangst du wirklich
fantastischen Rabatt angeboten die von
40% für das Jahresabo bis zu 85% auf die
lebenslange Mitgliedschaft reichen also
zöger oder nicht du dir was Gutes und
bringt ein Englisch endlich auf ein
geschliffenes Level egal ob du im
Silicon Karriere machen willst oder
woanders perfekte Aussprache hat noch
nie geschafft und falls Du uns etwas
gutes tun möchtest in der Beschreibung
findest du auch einen Spenden Link mit
dem du unsere Arbeit finanziell
unterstützen kannst auch das für euch
auch in Zukunft noch mit viel
interessanten Videos beglücken kann so
und nun zurück zum Thema dieses Videos
und zur Beantwortung unserer Fragen die
wir so oft mit einem schnellen Blick in
die Geschichte beginnen werden
es war einmal in Amerika
wenn es visualpolitik schon in den 50er
Jahren gegeben hätte hätten wir
garantiert immer wieder über zwei Orte
gesprochen das Silicon Valley und
deadroid die Geschichte von the troll
ist ja recht gut bekannt die
Industriestadt an der kanadischen Grenze
war Amerikas Motown hier schlug das Herz
der US Automobilindustrie hier war der
Sitz der drei großen Autokonzerne
General Motors Ford und Chrysler und
deshalb zogen in der ersten Hälfte des
20 Jahrhunderts sehr viele Menschen
dorthin die Einwohnerzahl von Detroit
steht bis 1950 auf fast 2 Millionen
Menschen und sein Umland wuchs noch
lange kräftig weiter ein anderer
erfolgreicher Magnet für Menschen war in
den Vereinigten Staaten ab den 1950er
Jahren aber auch das Silikon Berlin und
einmal Magnet ist es im Gegensatz zu
Detroit bis heute geblieben aber wisst
ihr was der Grundstein für den Erfolg
des weltbekannten hightektals in
Kalifornien war nein nur es war nichts
anderes als der Krieg
ja ihr habt richtig gehört denn für die
Vereinigten Staaten von der Zweite
Weltkrieg ja nicht nur in Europa statt
sondern noch mehr im Pazifik gegen Japan
deshalb wurden an der Westküste massiv
Investitionen getätigt und Arbeitskräfte
eingestellt und alle Arten von Fabriken
und Unternehmen aufzubauen des Militär
belieferten das fruchtbare Tiefland
südlich von San Francisco bis dahin er
Obstanbaugebiet war so richtigen Zeit am
richtigen Ort es lag nicht nur eine
Westküste sondern verfügte auch über
eine große akademische Community in
palualto und damit über
hochqualifizierte Fachkräfte und da der
Krieg nicht nur Rohstoffe und einfache
Waffen sondern auch für die damalige
Zeit sehr fortschrittliche Technologien
erforderte kam diese Gegend mächtig in
Schwung zum Beispiel begann hier viele
Unternehmen neuartige Dioden und
Transistoren fürs Militär zu entwickeln
und so wurde das was später als legten
Willi bekannt werden sollte schon
während des Zweiten Weltkriegs und dann
im Kalten Krieg ein wichtiger
technologiestand war
[Musik]
diese Saat ging auf denn das Silicon
Valley war nicht nur für Obstbäume
sondern auch für Unternehmen besonders
druckbarer Boden einer derjenigen die
für diese wirtschaftliche Blüte
verantwortlich waren ist der Mann den
ihr jetzt seht
die Rede ist von Professor Frederic
Traummann dem Vater eine engen
Kooperation zwischen Universitäten und
Privatwirtschaft Terminal
University verstand das Universitäten
zwar rechtlich Wissen produzieren das
ist aber die Unternehmer sind die diese
Kenntnisse in Entwicklungen und
Innovationen umsetzen also in für die
Gesellschaft nützliche neue Anwendungen
und Produkte mit dieser Idee im
Hintergrund arbeitet er unermüdlich
daran seine Hochschule für Unternehmen
zu öffnen und die Beziehung zu
Wirtschaft zu festigen gemäß einer
Vision sollten Unternehmen die
Forschungsprojekte der Universität
finanzieren und fördern wodurch die
Universität viel mehr Ressourcen und
praktische Orientierungshilfe bekommt
andererseits würde die Zusammenarbeit
mit der Uni ist in Unternehmen
ermöglichen schneller zu wachsen und
somit letztendlich selbst mehr
Ressourcen zu haben
auch für weitere Forschung um diesen
sich selbstverstärkenden und stets
beschleunigenden Kreislauf in Gang zu
setzen fehlte allerdings noch ein
anderer Schlüsselfaktor den Unternehmen
immer dringend brauchen das ist die
nächste billionenfrage aber die ist
eigentlich ziemlich simpel
ich meine was braucht die interessierten
Unternehmen wohl am meisten dazu klar
Geld viel Geld und an dieser Stelle kam
ein anderer Herr den ihr jetzt sieht ins
Spiel Lawrence Rockefeller der Gründer
des ersten Risikokapital France
der Rest ist Geschichte
um es anders auszudrücken der Erfolg des
Silicon Valley beruht nicht nur darauf
das ist dort viele Unternehmen und
Unternehmer gibt die hat es ja fast
überall der Unterschied war das im
Silicon Valley Bedingungen entstanden
unter denen ein Unternehmen aus dem
Nichts entstehen kann und innerhalb
weniger Jahre so wächst das ist an der
Wall Street notiert wird denn ein
Börsengang ist ja vor allem dass du da
noch mehr Kapital hereinzubringen das
ist schließlich die Geschichte von
Google Facebook Apple und so vielen
anderen Konzernen die unser Leben
verändert haben und die Frage lautet nun
was hat das seligen Valley was Europa
nicht hat Flexibilität steht an erster
Stelle möglich für zwei konkurrierende
Unternehmen gleichzeitig zu arbeiten
kein Problem prima kann man jemanden
feiern der nicht rentabel arbeitet und
stattdessen schnell jemanden wieder
anheuern der ist besser kann okay noch
besser aber das ist nicht alles im
Silicon Valley gibt es noch zwei weitere
Schlüsselfaktoren die Kooperation von
Universitäten und Industrie und
reichlich Risiko Kapital das
Gegenbeispiel dazu ist
ist oder besser gesagt war die
Weltmetropole des Autobaus die
Autoindustrie ist eine in Würde gereifte
Branche in der es aber viel weniger
bahnbrechende Innovationen gibt sie kann
immer bessere Autos bauen aber es sind
halt immer noch nur Autos und aus diesem
Grund taten die dortigen altenessenen
Konzerne fort Chryslers weiterhin das
was ihr am besten konnten Autos bauen es
dauerte nicht lange bis sie auf einen
starken Konkurrenten stießen der
billigere aber genauso gute Autos
Angebot nämlich die Japaner japanische
Konzerne wie Toyota begann den
us-automat aufzuholen
[Musik]
wurde vernachlässigt eine Fülle von
Problemen mit Gewerkschaften steuern und
Regularien aller Art eine ständig
steigende Kriminalität und die wachsende
Konkurrenz durch neue asiatische Marken
veranlassten die US-Unternehmen ihre
Fabriken in der Stadt zu schließen der
Grund sie waren schlicht und einfach
nicht mehr wettbewerbsfähig wir haben
über das Schicksal Detroit übrigens ein
eigenes Video auf visualpolitik gedreht
ich werde euch verlinken der Niedergang
direkt so extrem dass die eins von fast
2 Millionen Menschen bewohnte Stadt
heute nur noch magere 630.000 Einwohner
zählt
zwei Drittel der Bevölkerung sind
einfach weg ihr seht also sowohl das
Silicon Valley als auch der Truck
boomten wie kaum ein anderes Gebiet in
den Staaten aber nur eines hat es
geschafft zu überleben der Schlüssel
dafür war was wir bereits erwähnt haben
Innovation
in gewisser Weise kann man sagen dass
die Europäische Union heute mit ganz
ähnlichen Bedrohungen konfrontiert ist
wie deadroid im Laufe der Jahre haben
Vorschriften steuern und Arbeitspolitik
die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit etablierter
Unternehmen untergraben und jetzt droht
die Energiekrise so etwas wie die letzte
Erschütterung zu sein die das
Krankenhaus zum Einsturz bringt das ist
vor allem deshalb ein Problem weil
Europa vereinfacht gesagt einfach nichts
Neues mehr hervorbringt
die Frage ist also berechtigt ist Europa
auf dem gleichen Weg wie Detroit genau
das werden wir jetzt tiefer ergründen
das alte Europa
[Musik]
schauen wir uns mal folgende Grafik an
wie ihr seht gibt Europa nicht nur viel
weniger als die USA für Verteidigung aus
die europäischen Ausgaben sind auch noch
auf diverse Länder aufgesplittert und
sie gießen dabei fast ausschließlich im
Gehälter und laufende Ausgaben mit
anderen Worten es bleibt in Europa wenig
übrig um in Forschung und Entwicklung
und völlig neue militärprogramme zu
investieren wir können also schon mal
festhalten dass Europa einer jener
Innovationsmotoren fehlt die die USA
haben denn ganz egal ob ihr nun für oder
gegen hohe Militärausgaben seid im
Gegensatz zu anderen Arten von
öffentlichen Ausgaben handelt es sich
dabei meist um Investitionen in
angewandte hochwertige Technologie
doch es ist nicht das einzige Problem
selbst wenn sich alle europäischen
Armenien darauf einigen würden eine
gemeinsame Waffe zu entwickeln z.B ein
neues Raketensystem würden sie auf ein
großes Problem stoßen vielen
europäischen Universitäten ist es
nämlich verboten an militärischen
Projekten mitzuarbeiten ja ihr habt euch
nicht verhört es ist verboten es gibt
Unis die sich Stimmung auferlegt haben
die es verbieten an militärischen
Projekten zu forschen klar man findet
auch in Europa Militärforschung und
Universitäten die nicht so streng mit
sich selbst sind aber die
Kooperationsmöglichkeiten zwischen
Militär und Wissenschaft und hierzulande
um viele Größenordnungen kleiner als in
den USA und sie stoßen vor allem auch in
der Öffentlichkeit auf viel weniger
Akzeptanz zudem sind manche Unis auf
prinzipiell nicht bereit mit privaten
Unternehmen zusammen zu arbeiten
im elfenbeinkommen und das ist ein
großes Problem denn wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass sehr viele militärische
Innovationen Ende zivile Anwendungen
nach sich ziehen Paradebeispiele sind
dafür dass Navigationssystem GPS oder
das Internet
selbstverständlich dürfen wir nicht
alles auf dem Militär Ausgaben verengen
hinzu kommt der Umstand das europäische
Universitäten mehr auf die Lehre als auf
die Forschung ausgerichtet sind wir
haben schon in früheren visualpolitik
wie wir uns darüber gesprochen die
Universitäten in den USA sind extrem
teuer das hat aber auch ein Vorteil sie
bringen Ergebnisse hervor dieser weitere
Motor der amerikanischen
Innovationskraft ist in Europa als auch
viel viel schwächer erschwerend kommt
hinzu dass die Europäische Union eine
regulierungsmaschine ist ihre
Hauptaufgabe scheint darin zu bestimmen
alles zu regulieren was reguliert werden
kann und das erschwert Innovationen
ändern die EU arbeitet zum Beispiel
bereits an der Regulierung der
künstlichen Intelligenz Unternehmen die
mit KI-Forschung beginnen wollen müssen
also mit viel Hindernissen und Auflagen
aller Art rechnen Medikamente sind ein
weiteres gutes Beispiel die Vorschriften
sind so strengt dass es Jahrzehnte
dauern kann bis Unternehmen neue
Medikamente auf den Markt bringen können
kaum Investitionen im täglich logologie
und Universitäten die nur ungern
operieren und eine Menge Vorschriften
das Grundprinzip lässt sich ganz gut in
folgenden Worten zusammenfassen
da wir bei der Innovation nicht führend
sein können sollten wir bei der
Regulierung führen sein Aussage eines
hier besser nicht genannten Abgeordneten
des Europaparlaments gegenüber
visualpolitik EU-Vorschriften können
sogar Investitionen in Innovationen
verhindern
natürlich gibt es immer Ausnahmen wie
gesagt SAP Skype oder biontech aus Mainz
das mit seinem Corona Impfstoff aber es
ist schon merkwürdig dass einer der
größten risikokapitalfonds Sequoia
Kapitel nicht einmal Büros in der
Europäischen Union unterhält er ist in
den USA in Großbritannien Indien und
China vertreten hat sich aber nicht
einmal die Mühe gemacht ein Büro in
einer EU-Hauptstadt zu eröffnen und das
illustriert warum es in Europa kaum
Einhörner gibt ich meine damit jetzt
nicht die netten Fabelwesen sondern
Unicorns im Finanzamt solche einhörner
sind Startups die mindestens eine
Milliarde Dollar wert sind ihr könnt
Euch sicher denken woher die meisten von
ihnen kommen richtig aus den Vereinigten
Staaten das Land der unbegrenzten
Möglichkeiten hier ist es mal keine
Plattitüde hat die meisten Einhörner
hervorgebracht ganze 487 danach von
China mit 300 und einem Einhorn und erst
auf den fünften Platz finden wir einen
EU-Staat Deutschland war immerhin 26
Einhörner
[Musik]
aber gibt es in der Europäischen Union
denn gar kein Land das dem Silicon
Berlin nahe kommt nun am ähnlichsten ist
den noch Estland hier auch wieso Politik
haben wir schon mehrere Videos gedreht
die das Essener Modell eingehend erklärt
ist lang ist ein Staat der immerhin
versucht hat sich von denen in Europa
vorherrschende politischen Standards zu
lösen so haben die ersten z.B einen sehr
attraktiven steuerlichen Rahmen für
Unternehmen geschaffen wie kein anderes
Land hat Estland seine digitale
Infrastruktur entwickelt und hat dafür
gekämpft Vorschriften zu begrenzen oder
zumindest ihre Einhaltung zu erleichtern
wo ist dann das Problem nun ist lang ist
ein winziges Land es hat nur etwas mehr
als eine Million Einwohner daher ist
seine Bedeutung von ganz Europa
natürlich begrenzt
hat sich Europa also auf seine Lorbeeren
ausgeruht und einfach kein Interesse ein
eigenes Leben Valley zu bekommen nun
meine Lieben Zuschauer bis vor kurzem
schien das für die Europäische Union
wirklich keine große Rolle zu spielen
[Musik]
so lange russisches Gas reichlich und
reibungslos in die EU und insbesondere
nach Deutschland floss blieben die
Unternehmen wettbewerbs- und der EU-Raum
eben gerade wegen seiner niedrigen
Energiepreise attraktiv für
Investitionen verkürzt ausgedrückt
billige Energie hat alle anderen
negativfraktoren weggemacht nun sind die
Gaspreise jedoch in die Höhe schnell das
meiste Gas kommt verflüssigt an und
zudem nicht mehr aus Russland für Europa
bedeutet das dass Risiko das Unternehmen
abwandern hat sich dadurch vervielfacht
immerhin die Europäische Union sucht
inzwischen nach Wegen um gegenüber den
USA und China konkurrenzfähig zu werden
die Frage ist nur wie sie das anstellen
will soll sie versuchen ihr eigenes
silicon Welt zu schaffen welche
Voraussetzungen hat Europa dafür zu
bieten ist so eine Vision wirklich
realistisch nun aufgepasst denn auf
jeden Fall hat die Europäische Union
gerade jetzt eine einmalige Chance dazu
einen Neuanfang
habt ihr eine Ahnung wie viele
europäische Einhörner in der weltweiten
Top Ten vertreten sind na was meint ihr
drei zwei oder eines ihr habt es wohl
schon erraten 0 sehr hoch keines die Top
Ten der globalen Einhörner wird was
nicht weiter überraschend ist von China
und den USA dominiert
erst auf Platz 10 kommt mal eine anderes
Land aber das ist Singapur man kann zwar
nicht sagen dass die Europäische Union
es nicht versucht hätte seit 2008 wurden
mehrere Programme zur Finanzierung von
Forschung und Entwicklung und zur
Innovationsförderung aufgelegt natürlich
sind diese mit europäischen Geldern
finanzierten Projekte zumindest
irgendwie interessant und
perspektivrechtlich aber leider bleiben
die meisten von ihnen in der Regel auf
den Niveau netter akademischer Papiere
und Präsentation hängt sie werden nie in
reale Produkt umgesetzt die sich
absetzen und auf dem Markt durchsetzen
könnten das liegt unter anderem daran
dass öffentliche Programme in der Regel
sehr stark und bürokratisch sind und
sich fast nie an der Markttauglichkeit
des ergebnissesorientiert die Tatsache
dass Beamte oder Bürokraten für die
Auswahl der zu finanzierenden Projekte
zuständig sind scheint keine
bahnbrechende Strategie zu sein eines
der technologische erfolgreichsten
Länder der letzten Jahrzehnte ist Israel
und was glaubt ihr was man dort gemacht
hat und man hat diese Bürokraten einfach
aus dem Vergabeprozess ausgeklappt die
machten die staatliche Finanzierung zu
einer Ergänzung der privaten
Finanzierung aus diesem Grund ist es
dort die private Seite die für die
Auswahl der Projekte zuständig ist in
die sie dann aber auch ihr eigenes Geld
stecken mussten
okay so weit so schlecht für die
Europäer aber nicht den Kopf in den Sand
stecken wenn die Situation in Europa
könnte sich aus einem einfachen Grund
noch ändern und dieser ist ausgerechnet
der russische Krieg in der Ukraine
nach dem Putin beschlossen hatte in die
Ukraine einzumarschieren reagierten die
EU-Staaten mit höheren Militärausgaben
das Resultat waren dann Nachrichten wie
diese Polen stellt
rekordverteidigungshaushalt für 2023 vor
die polnische Regierung hatte
Staatshaushalt 2023 vorgelegt der eine
noch nie da gewesene Erhöhung der
Verteidigungsausgaben vorsieht die den
Rekordwert von 20,66 Milliarden
US-Dollar erreichen sollen mit mehr als
drei Prozent des BIP ist der polnische
Verteidigungshaushalt 2023 nominal 69%
höher als der von 2022 und mehr als
dreimal so hoch wie 2014 die
europäischen Verteidigungsausgaben sind
keine Witz mehr für das Jahr 2023 wird
erwartet dass Deutschland und die 19
anderen NATO-Länder die sich nach dem
einmal Russland in die Ukraine zu einer
Erhöhung der Verteidigungsausgaben
verpflichtet haben diese Pläne durch
eine militärische Einkaufs
umsetzen aufgrund des Putin shocks
werden alle europäischen Staaten relativ
kurzfristig ihrem Militärausgaben ver
und wie es aussieht durchlaufen diese
neuen Militärausgaben in der
Europäischen Union 3 Phasen in einer
ersten Phase geht es um eine
Feinabstimmung aller real vorhandenen
militärischen Mittel im schlagzeil wie
diese in Zukunft zu vermeiden Bundeswehr
in Not Deutschlands Munition reicht wohl
nur für zwei Tage Krieg die zweite Phase
wäre die Erneuerung veraltete Ausrüstung
zum Beispiel mit einem umfangreichen
Ankauf von F35 Kampfjet aus den USA und
schließlich käme eine dritte Phase in
der die Europäer eigene Waffensysteme
neu entwickeln hier wird es schließlich
spannend denn dabei wird die Entwicklung
neuer Technologien maßgeblich sein
tatsächlich könnte dies die Saat
darstellen die europa braucht um eine
Art eigenes linken Valley zum Blühen zu
bringen
[Musik]
erst als Europa in die Krise geriet und
sich gegen einen äußeren Feind Verein
musste wurde Joseph Borell erhöht
entweder wer investieren massiv in
verteidigungsinvestitionen oder wir
werden militärisch irrelevant gius
Vertreter der EU für außen und
Sicherheitspolitik
reinmetall bauten neue
munitionsfertigung in Deutschland auf
Rheinmetall baut in Deutschland eine
umfangreiche neue munitionsfertigung mit
dem Ziel einer unabhängigen Versorgung
der Bundeswehr auf es verwies auch auf
erheblichen Nachholbedarf bei Munition
in Deutschland und Lücken die durch die
Unterstützung der Ukraine entstanden
sind im Mittelpunkt der neuen
Bedarfslage steht das Bestreben die
Munitionsversorgung in Deutschland
wieder prinzipiell unabhängig von
ausländischen Fertigungsstätten
aufzustellen wo das Problem liegt Europa
hat 27 verschiedene Armeen und es kostet
viel Geld eine Kampfjet oder einen
Panzer zu entwickeln der mit den
US-Modellen mithalten kann es gibt
mehrere Programme der Europäischen Union
um Forschung und Entwicklung zwischen
Organisation in verschiedenen Ländern zu
fördern doch die Ergebnisse sind eher
bescheiden was also könnte die Lösung
sein gemeinsame Projekte von zwei drei
oder mehreren Ländern das war die Formel
mit der einige relativ erfolgreiche
Projekte wieder Eurofighter oder die
Euro Drohne entstanden sind sogar ein
Unternehmen wie Airbus das einen sehr
bedeutenden militärischen Bereich hat
ist auch der Zusammenarbeit mehrerer
Staaten hervorgegangen auch neuen
Situation könnten sich nun mehrere
europäische Staaten zusammentun und
einen öffentlichen Wettbewerb für die
Entwicklung eines neuen Kampfjets oder
eines neuen cybersicherheitssystems
ausrufen denn mehrere Staaten zusammen
können viel mehr Geld investieren als
einzelne
zweifellos könnte eine solche neue
Geldflut für die militärische Forschung
das entstehen neue Hightech Cluster
unterstützen sowie einst in Israel oder
in Silicon Valley in diesem Aspekt hat
militärische Forschungsarbeit mehrere
Vorteile gegenüber anderen Arten von
öffentlichen Ausgaben erstens wird die
Förderung der angewandten Entwicklung
und Forschung angestrebt mit anderen
Worten es wird Geld mit einer klaren
Absicht ausgegeben neue Projekte und
Technologien zu entwickeln die für
bestimmte Produkte und Dienstleistungen
eingesetzt werden zweitens stützt sich
die militärische Forschung auf private
Unternehmen und ist eng mit dem
industriellen Produktionsprozess
verbunden und drittens wird in der Regel
auch berücksichtigt dass diese
Technologie später für den Export
geeignet sein soll denn die
Rüstungsindustrie ist nun mal sehr
kapitalintensiv und eine neue
Entwicklung ist nur dann rentabel wenn
sie später in großer Serien produziert
werden kann diese drei großen Vorteile
bedeuten dass Militärausgaben in der
Regel relativ effizient sind wenn es
darum geht eine neue
technologieindustrie zu fördern
zumindest erwiesen sie sich in der
Vergangenheit als effizien weiter
gegenüber anderen Arten von Förderungen
aber natürlich reicht Geld allein nicht
aus es braucht noch mehr
konkret gefragt was muss ich in Europa
ändern damit all dieses Geld in
innovative Unternehmen umgewandelt
werden kann
nun es sind drei Dinge erforderlich
erstens ist es wichtig dass die Staaten
bereit sind bei der Verteidigung
zusammen zu arbeiten und das ist leider
alles andere als einfach stellt euch zum
Beispiel einer vor Spanien Frankreich
und Italien tun sich zusammen um ein
Projekt für künstliche Intelligenz zu
entwickeln da kommen sofort jede Menge
Fragen auf wo wird die Produktion
eingerichtet welche Universität wird in
Löwenanteil der Forschung betreiben ist
Land A wirklich bereit zu Finanzierung
eines Projektes beizutragen das vor
allem Arbeitsplätze im Landschaft und
inlandsee die Forschung stärkt diese Art
von Diskussionen und geschafft hat kann
die schönsten Projekte um Jahre
verzögern und allzu oft führen sie nur
zu kosten Explosionen zweitens ist es
wichtig dass die Hochschulen an solchen
Rüstungsprojekten teilnehmen können
Europas Universitäten müssen sich daran
gewöhnen mit privaten Unternehmen
zusammen zu arbeiten und ihren Argwohn
gegen militärische Anwendungen
überwinden
[Musik]
und drittens muss Europa vieler seine
Vorschriften lockern die diese Art von
Aktivitäten derzeit behindern eine Idee
wäre die Einrichtung von
Sonderwirtschaftszonen nach dem Vorbild
eines von experiministerin List trust in
Großbritannien vorgeschlagenen Modells
sie skizzierte Wirtschaftszonen in denen
städtebauliche Vorschriften
Geschäftsregeln oder Steuern gelockert
oder besser an die Realität dieser
Branche angepasst werden all dies würde
es ermöglichen dass ich ohnehin
abzeichnende militärische Wettrüsten in
ganz Europa zumindest in ein neues
Silikon Berlin zu verwandeln
oder was meint ihr wird Europa noch sein
eigenes Silicon Valley bekommen oder
sind die europäischen Erklärungen und in
denen nur schöne Worte kann dies den
Verlust an Wettbewerbsfähigkeit aufgrund
höhere Energiepreise ausgleichen und
kann die EU das Risiko umschiffen das
war viele Mini silicon valleys entstehen
diese aber keine echte
Entwicklungsdynamik entfalten oder wird
Europa stattdessen um bei unserem
Gegenbeispiel zu bleiben als bald zu
einem gigantischen Detroit verkommen
bitte schreibt uns eure Antworten und
Gedanken dazu in die Kommentare und
vergiss bitte nicht dass wir hier auf
diese Politik jede Woche neue Videos
veröffentlichen also falls noch nicht
geschehen abonniert bitte unseren Kanal
und klickt auch auf die kleine Glocke
damit ihr keines unserer Updates
verpasst wenn euch dieses Video gefallen
hat gebt ihm bitte einen like als wenn
eure Freunde und vergesst nicht eine
kleine Spende an uns damit wir dieses
Projekt weiterführen können wir sehen
uns beim nächsten Mal macht's gut und
bis bald
[Musik]